welcome back everyone
our next topic is canadian ai research
for good you've heard that phrase
a little bit already today as in the
last session we'll look forward to
addressing audience questions at the end
and i invite you to submit your
questions throughout our discussion
using the zoom q a function and so
what do we mean when we say canadian ai
research for good
well as many of you know the rapid pace
of ai development has already had a
major impact across
sectors and it shows no signs of slowing
down
so how can we as ai researchers and
developers
ensure that these technologies will
benefit everyone and that the race to
deploy ai won't supersede
important principles like privacy
security ethics and equity
and so audience let's get you active on
the chat what do you think what are the
top three things
that come to mind when you think of
canadian ai
research for good send in your thoughts
on the chat
and so while you're doing that i'm
excited to welcome some of the newest
members of the canada cfar ai chairs
program
each of our chairs are leading important
research in areas that will have a real
positive impact on society and so i'll
invite
mo niddy david and rahul to open
to turn on your cameras and join me on
screen and let me introduce
my colleagues the four of the new canada
cfr ai chairs with us today
we have mo chen an amy fellow an
assistant professor at the school of
computing science at simon fraser
university
that's what he's got in his background
moe's research specializes in developing
safe robotics
we have nitty hegde and amy fellow an
associate professor at the department of
computing science at the university of
alberta
niti is building machine learning
methods that allow technologies to
operate
while at the same time protecting our
privacy
david rolnick is here hi david he's a
faculty member
at mila and an assistant professor at
mcgill university school of computer
science
he's also one of the co-founders of
climate change ai
and one of the areas that his research
focuses on is
using ai in the fight against climate
change
and we have rahul g krishnan rahul is a
member of the vector institute
he's an alum of the university of
toronto and he is returning
very shortly to take up his first
faculty position in canada
as an assistant professor of computer
science and medicine
rahul's research is using machine
learning to understand how disease
progresses
over time using electronic health
records thank you to the four of you for
joining us and congratulations once more
so let's have a great discussion i know
our audience will have lots of questions
don't forget to
send those in using the q a function and
we'll start with just a few
uh structured questions before we get to
the audience
and so i'll ask in fact each of you to
describe
your current research um and and tell us
what ways your research can be applied
to deliver positive social benefits
we're going to start with
mo okay yeah thanks so much alyssa for
the introduction and for hosting the
event
so i guess i can talk about my research
for a while but maybe
i'll give the short version so my
current research aims to enable robots
to behave safely and naturally among
people
so we work on topics such as human
intending prints
collision avoidance for mobile robots
multi-agent coordination
so our techniques can be applied to
indoor places like schools
and stores and also outdoors as well
so i think the key here is to be safe
for robots to be safe but still useful
so of course a robot can be completely
safe if it operates far from people
or if for example a car a self-driving
car is just staying apart right
but uh but we need to like to go further
than that we need to walk the fine line
between
um interacting closely with people and
and still staying safe and hopefully
trust it eventually
yes eventually be our partners in
much of the work that we do right right
right yeah
yes so maybe getting a little bit more
technical of um
so our methodology involves control
theory reinforcement learning
computer vision so for example we try to
adapt safety verification algorithms
that
are used in the aerospace to crowded
environments on the ground
we also try to combine classical
optimization techniques
with data driven uh learning based
methods so we have uh
several examples of that like one of
them i like to bring up is
like we try to use learning based
methods to do higher level planning
um like where the robot should go next
at a high level and then the details of
how to get there safely can be taken
care of
by some of these classical algorithms
yeah so
i guess you asked the second part of the
question uh positive societal benefits
autonomous robots today are often used
in controlled environments like
warehouses
or maybe in the absence of other agents
like robots and people
um so i hopefully my research will allow
us to allow robots
to interact with people more closely for
applications
such as like maybe a robot assistant
delivery vehicles
autonomous cars and for example in one
project uh
we put a collision avoidance system on
robots and then we have students
try to drive a robot into a wall or into
obstacles in unknown environments
and the well they tried but they failed
to cause a collision so that's
uh that's a really cool experiment and
we are also working on something called
the follow ahead project
where a robot tries to autonomously stay
in front of a person
so kind of imagine you have a shopping
cart but
instead of you pushing a shopping cart
it's kind of just pushing itself
in front of you so i think i'll stop
here
those are some some great examples of
fun graduate research projects going on
your lab thanks for sharing those
nitty over to you tell us about your
research and uh
how it's it's driving towards delivering
positive
uh benefits for society
yeah hi elissa thank you for the
introduction and for
hosting this very interesting event
so my current research is um in
looking at privacy and fairness and
machine learning
so what i'm interested in is looking at
real practical problems where
some of the current privacy preserving
methods don't really fit very well
and what are the fundamentals that we
need to work on in order to get that
working
so for example a lot of data is
structured for example the data that
you're producing when you're on social
networks
which means you know a data point is not
necessarily independent of the other
data points
um there's related somehow and this
could be for example in the structure of
a graph
if we have apply standard privacy
preserving methods
then this doesn't scale well to the size
so you can't look at large data sets
anymore
the the the noise and the the privacy
cost that you would
need compute power you would need would
quickly
um be predictive so i'm looking at that
kind of
question another example is let's say um
different partners in machine learning
and ai want to share data
but you know we don't want to share
actual data because of privacy concerns
so we might want to
create synthetic data sets and share
those but
synthetic data sets are not private by
themselves so we need to do something
else to make them private
there are some methods out there but
they're very specific to certain tasks
so how can we generalize this
and another interesting problem is how
does privacy interplay with fairness
can we have both in a particular
machine learning model some pre
preliminary work has shown that it's not
possible for
all um conditions to have both
so how do we make sure can we devise new
algorithms that make sure that we can
have a privacy preserving outcome
that is also fair your research really
sort of reminds me that you know we need
to strike such a fine balance between
privacy and data access in order to be
able to do the machine learning research
that we've been talking about today
of course we need researchers need
access to data and so that's why
your work is so critical any other
thoughts on the social benefits
yeah so obviously um you know by
by the definition of the problems i'm
working at it has obvious social
benefits
um you know uh machine learning ai
really impacts every part of our lives
so anywhere that we can limit
um damage or harm like privacy breaches
or biased outcomes that lead to
decisions that
impact people in their daily lives for
instance
um is important so um you know this type
of work has a
clear end goal which is to um
safeguard people from you know potential
outcomes
and impacts on all of us as individuals
yeah great thank you very much
um rahul over to you tell us about your
research and
it's it's opportunity for uh positive
social benefits thanks so much
um so i thank you again for organizing
this wonderful set of
talks and panels um my own research
maybe i'll start with a bit of
historical context and so
over the last three decades there
has been an increasing realization that
a lot of the healthcare data that's been
digitized by hospitals
as they went to record how patients
interacted with the healthcare system
can be of use beyond the original intent
that these records were created for
so originally a lot of these healthcare
records were created for bookkeeping and
for billing purposes across
north america and in the last few
decades what we've seen is that
people have been interested in
understanding how the patterns that lie
within these data
can be used for the creation of machine
learning models to automate clinically
meaningful
tasks and so um why might that be
interesting
uh well for one we know that access to
healthcare and the quality of healthcare
access that people do have is not
equally distributed so part of the pitch
for this line of work
is to help transfer some of the
knowledge that may exist in high
resource settings the lower resource
settings
via the use of predictive models in
machine learning
and so more broadly my work lies at this
intersection
of machine learning and healthcare and
within it i do
research both in applied areas as well
as more methodological areas
and so to give two concrete examples of
some of the applied work that i do
uh one is on this idea of patient risk
stratification
which is to say can we use algorithms
and models for machine learning
to find patterns in patient data to
predict whether or not
they will have adverse outcomes in the
future now
at the outset this looks like a fairly
standard
predictive problem but i think once you
delve into it you begin to understand
some of the nuances that exist
because healthcare data is not as clean
as some of the data that exists and is
commonly used in machine learning
there's many potential biases that one
has to navigate in order to ensure that
the underlying model that's being
learned
is a true uh and good model
of a faithful model rather of the
outcome that one cares about predicting
the second example is that of disease
progression which is to say
doctors often collect large cohorts of
patients that corres
who all suffer from a common disease and
so
in the context of that problem one
interesting question there
is how can we use this data to
understand diseases better
which is to say this diabetes have
predictable
patterns of evolution within the human
population
and if we were able to use machine
learning to discover those predictable
patterns of evolution
can those then lead doctors to ask
new and interesting hypotheses about how
to treat the disease better
so really using machine learning as a
tool for hypothesis discovery
and what i found during the course of my
own research is the fact that these
problems will often require new machine
learning advances as well in order to be
able to tackle them effectively
so in the past i've worked on new
algorithms for probabilistic inference
and non-linear models
as well as new techniques to reduce the
sample complexity or rather to reduce
how data hungry these models are because
often in healthcare one does not
always have access to millions and
millions of samples
in order to learn these machine learning
models so
in the future i i'm interested in
thinking about how to make use of some
of the advances that we have in causal
inference
to build automated clinical decision
making support tools
as well as thinking about some of the
nuances of deploying machine learning
models in hospitals how do we tackle
issues like
the fact that our distribution of people
changes over time
it's not the same people going into the
hospital and that has downstream effects
on how well any deployed machine
learning algorithm performs
and finally to tackle this question that
you asked of societal benefit
i think there's a few ways in which this
broad area can deliver some form of
societal benefit
and and this is particularly true in the
case of canada where there's a
uh where the provincial systems are set
up in a way to provide health care for
everyone
and so one is in the context of early
prediction or risk stratification for
chronic diseases
there are certain diseases where if you
were to predict
early that a patient is at risk for
continuing on to develop that disease
there may be interventions that one can
take and prevent
the development of chronic versions of
that disease in that patient
and so diabetes
is one simple example of it where if a
patient is put on
a diet and exercise regimen prior to the
development of chronic diabetes
they can often stave off some of the
comorbidities that are associated with
that disease
and so this is a case where predictive
models can lead to interventions
which can then lead to better public
health outcomes both from a cost
perspective but more importantly from a
human health perspective
the second is in the context of
developing these predictive models and
deploying them in some of the lower
resource settings
where and and and in doing so reduce
some of the inequality that exists in
access to healthcare
so i'll conclude with that and i hope i
uh answered some of the key
questions that you asked thank you for
for going into your
your areas of interest and some of the
issues surrounding
uh ai for health research and innovation
in in detail you know
it's an area i think that we have
tremendous opportunity in canada to
really play a leadership role in
understanding uh you know how ai and
machine learning can be applied within
canada's healthcare systems the many
multiple systems we have in each of our
provinces and territories
uh but we have such great expertise in
this country and i think a lot of will
to think really critically about uh
deploying ai within our health systems
and
um a huge part of what we have to do is
is uh
work with citizens and patients in the
public to help them to understand what
the benefits are
of bringing ai into our systems and i
think they're they're multiple so thank
you for your work
on on this topic david last but not
least your work is is really fascinating
tell us about your research and
its uh positive impact on society thank
you so much it's a pleasure to be here
i work on applications of ai to climate
change
so helping society to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions
and also respond to the effects of
climate change and that means
applications in areas like
energy and transportation buildings and
urban planning
sustainable forestry and agriculture
ecology and
disaster response now climate change is
a
huge and multi-faceted problem and ai is
not going to solve it it's not a silver
bullet here
but it can be a powerful tool for
particular particular problems
um for example ai can help distill
large amounts of information to help
policy makers make decisions
for example by using satellite imagery
to automatically monitor greenhouse gas
emissions or
land use or monitor ecosystem change
it can also help optimize complicated
systems so for example
reducing the energy required to heat and
cool a building
or improving the efficiency of freight
transportation networks
it can improve forecasting for example
of agricultural productivity or food
insecurity
and it can also accelerate the process
of scientific discovery itself by
speeding up the search for new materials
like those in batteries or
in photovoltaics if you're interested in
the full space of where i
ai can be helpful in climate change we
actually put out a 100-page paper
with recommendations that's designed to
help guide this field moving forward
um but um let's dive into an example
from
from my research group one of the
challenges um to
using more solar and wind power is that
these sources of power vary from moment
to moment depending upon
whether the sun is shining or the wind
is blowing that means it's really
difficult to control an electrical grid
with lots of renewables
because the available supply of
electricity is always changing
so basically grid operators need to
solve a large non-convex optimization
problem
it's called ac optimal power flow or
acopf in order to manage the
grid the existing ways to do this are
very slow
but the problem actually needs to be
solved every few minutes if you have a
lot of solar and wind energy
so in practice people have been
radically simplifying acopf in order to
make it more tractable and these
solutions
just not very good my
group just released a deep learning
algorithm that makes it possible to
derive
good and fast solutions to acopf by
encoding the constraints in the problem
state statement essentially providing a
guarantee
that the lights won't go out that it
will satisfy the constraints in the
electrical grid
and previous deep learning algorithms on
electrical grids couldn't do that which
is you can imagine made people much less
likely to apply them
because you know if you're a grid
operator you really want to make sure
the lights don't go out
so our approach actually not only works
for seo path but it also works for big
non-convex optimization problems in
general so it's very broadly useful
um some of the other projects in my
group are semi-supervised remote sensing
approaches for monitoring biodiversity
and ecological change
and fast approximate simulations of
atmospheric physics to integrate into
large weather and climate models
the existing models are great uh but key
components of them
like as with the electrical upgrade can
be very slow and machine learning
approximations can
speed some of those components up really
a key
aspect of our work across problems and
application domains
is close collaboration with domain
experts and other stakeholders like
the montreal insectarium and environment
and climate change canada
to ensure that the work is guided by the
societal benefits
and is deployed impactfully um and as
eliza mentioned i was a co-founder and
chair of
the climate change ai initiative uh
which facilitates work at this
intersection of climate change and
machine learning
we cultivate the global network of
researchers in the space we
organize workshops and advise
stakeholders and put out grants and
other
other resources great thank you david
you know
as i was listening and thinking about
all of you and your research one of the
things that
struck me and david noted it
specifically is it's highly
multidisciplinary right so you all
because you you want to apply your
machine learning tools and algorithms
and approaches
um to real world scenarios of course you
have to work with with people with
diverse expertise and so that i think
lends a real richness to your research
and
real opportunities to engage uh
scientists and researchers
outside of computer science in in the
application of ai it's very exciting
and then the other thing that struck me
too is that there are huge policy
questions related to
to all of your work as well too and so
there's another you know huge group of
stakeholders that we have the
opportunity to work with and share and
talk about our research so that they can
become more involved and understand
uh the challenges and opportunities of
applying machine learning to some of
these policy questions as well
it's great stuff guys okay so onto i'll
go back to my script and and uh stick to
the questions for a few minutes so
um all of you are taking up your first
faculty position in canada which is it's
fabulous we're so
happy to have you can you tell us each
why did you choose canada and the ai
institute that you're affiliated with as
the right place for you
to be pursuing your research and i'm
going to start with david david on this
one
sure so i i don't think i need to
convince this audience that canada
is at the forefront of innovation in ai
i'm really thrilled to be a part of the
seafarer ai community
both at mila and across canada
one of the things that i really love
about this program is that it represents
as alyssa was was
was indicating really an exceptional
opportunity for synergy between
research industry and policy which is
essential for
enabling impactful ai work on topics
like climate change
and many other topics innovation in ai
doesn't exist in isolation
it should be driven by problems of
relevance to society and it should be
developed
in conjunction with the various relevant
stakeholders
so those stakeholders can include
researchers in other fields like
energy agriculture or ecology in my case
but also the companies that are
often involved in implementing a
innovations um and the policymakers who
help shape the overall space
and very importantly end users people
and communities and sifa represents an
opportunity for communication between
many different voices
this is not just the way to build tools
that are most beneficial for society but
it's also the way to drive breakthroughs
in ai itself
so areas of cutting-edge ai research
like hybrid physical models
and interpretability are spurred on
by the needs of end stakeholders to
incorporate
known system constraints in this case or
to better understand
how the algorithm is working these are
the needs and that leads to innovation
so the right kind of research ecosystem
really benefits
everybody that's great thank you niddy
mindy what about you why did you choose
edmonton and amy
well actually i'm originally from
edmonton
and i was away for many years this is my
first faculty position but i've been
working for
about 18 19 years in industry research
and most of it about 17 of those years
in france
so this was a great opportunity for me
to not only come back
to canada but to edmonton and
to participate in this wonderful
ecosystem we have here
you know i echo what david um himself
said here
about um cfar uh
having giving us this opportunity to
make these short connections between
different parts of the country
um through amy mila and vector
you know which gives us you know a wide
range of people we can collaborate with
and topics like ma the one that i'm
working on
um you know it's really important to
connect with um
you know different disciplines uh
researchers
you know privacy impacts health for
example um
and it impacts um you know other
services like recommender systems so
um this is a great opportunity to be
able to connect with people of different
disciplines
and being in this academic environment
i'm also able to connect with
other disciplines like law and sociology
and business for example where we are
starting to see a lot of impacts of ai
as well
absolutely that's again that that
multi-disciplinary
uh collaboration is really what's key to
to driving these technologies and making
sure that they're implemented in a way
that's really
responsible and effective and so while
we're talking about
responsible ai and that's a phrase that
we we throw around a lot
uh in canada you heard it quite a bit
this morning from um
speakers um rahul moe let's talk about
your areas of application um you know
what are some of the important
considerations
that you think about or that the
community thinks about
in health or in robotics when it comes
to ensuring
that your ml approaches are implemented
in a way that is responsible
how about we'll start with raul uh
absolutely i think the area of
healthcare
is one where you cannot blindly walk in
and make the assumption that any black
box machine learning
algorithm will perform well and so this
is particularly true for two reasons
one there exists societal biases
that manifest in the data that what
these algorithms are trained on
and the naive application of these
algorithms
might simply amplify the existing biases
two
knowing what is relevant for the
prediction task at hand
is often not something that
most machine learning practitioners will
be well burst about
and furthermore what is relevant might
simply change
across the different context that the
model may be considered to be applied in
so what's relevant in hospital one for
predicting a patient
outcome may simply not be relevant in
hospital too because the way they do
things in terms of their processes is
fundamentally different
so i think in the context of healthcare
uh there's two key considerations
for uh thinking about responsible ai
that
i think are important to start with at
least and there's many many more
and so the first is working with domain
experts
i think there's absolutely no substitute
for working with a domain expert in
an area like healthcare because uh
he or she is the one who's worked with
the data
uh every day of their career and they
arguably
know about any limitations that the data
may have
and can think through the impacts of
those limitations on the downstream
performance
of any model that's being developed and
so the second key consideration i'd say
is monitoring the performance of the
model in any deployed solution
so um i think you know this notion of
responsible ai is not
uh it's not a one-off it doesn't stop
when the model
is done training it's uh sort of a
commitment to continue to see
how the model performs uh in a live
scenario
and moderate monitor it for unintended
consequences
and what i want to point out here is
that these unintended consequences
need not be from what the model is
predicting alone
they could be much bigger uh implied
consequences that come about
as the model is used in practice so to
ground that in a concrete example
you can think of a prediction tool that
say predicts whether or not a patient
should be
recommended for a second opinion uh for
in the context of say
a disease and so if this model is really
really
good at this prediction task what
essentially happens is that you have a
much larger volume of people
who are now going to doctors and
specialists for second opinions but we
have a finite set of resources
or a finite set of specialists who may
not have the capacity to handle that
volume
and so this is an unintended consequence
not due to the failure of the model but
rather due to the systemic nature
of the healthcare system that this model
is deployed in
and so i i'd say that like it's
important to think about both the micro
and the macro scale consequences
of deployed solutions and machine
learning in this context yeah absolutely
and and
both of those examples that you gave
remind me of especially in a healthcare
context this idea of you know the humans
in the loop right like so keeping the
clinicians very close to
the development of the machine learning
algorithms and tools that are being
deployed
but then uh you know we as as
practitioners
following uh the evolution of our models
as they are deployed
and out there in the wild so that's
that's great how about umo
tell us about um you know the the
considerations around responsible ai
when we're talking about robotics yeah
in fact i mean even though health and
robotics they sound like
kind of different areas i actually think
that there's a lot in common so one of
the things that we really worry about is
like if an ai makes a error in judgment
it's not just
some misclassified image but in both
robotics and health
there's i mean there's immediate
physical consequences
um to people uh so of course i think
safety and sort of the
reliability of these systems is really
really important
and i think it's actually one of the
bottlenecks that we need to get through
in order to kind of advance the the
field of robotics in
everyday life um i think a lot of these
key words i'm going to mention you
probably have heard like
interpretability right i think
robots will make mistakes and hopefully
not too many but they will make some
mistakes and when they do we need to
understand why
and systematically kind of um uh sort of
improve the areas that they're weak at
um i think one
one thing that i am pretty interested in
is uh
to have robots realize when they should
be unsure of themselves
so um so if you have like a if you have
a driver let's say a human driver or a
human
a doctor right especially during
training they
well training is now kind of an
overloaded term now
uh so what people know that people know
when they should be unsure and maybe
when they should ask help
right this is something that i don't
really think robots are can do yet and
hopefully they will be able to do this
later
um one thing that is also very important
for robotics is uh
how can we learn safely right one of the
ways of learning safely
is in simulation and so can we develop
methods
that can robustly transfer behavior
learn in simulation to the real world so
this is a very active area of research
um so in the end i think that one of the
really
more complex things that i could i want
to consider is really people's trust
um so suppose we make these systems
very technically robust uh technically
speaking they're very very
let's say safe will people still trust
them right
a lot of people a lot of times we we've
seen uh user studies where the robot is
behaving optimally but people
feel that feel that the robot is acting
weird and even though the robot is doing
probably better than humans humans don't
necessarily trust the robots
so in terms of trust i think it's a very
very difficult topic
um i think one thing that we we have to
do
as a community is to make sure we
educate everyone right not just the
students but
the entire community including people
who have already been working in ai
right we need to understand that we can
choose to be
we can choose to trust ai or maybe be
skeptical but
but the trust or skepticism it needs to
be informed
and and i think it's a as a community
this is a very important thing
in the long term and any any thoughts mo
on
on how we should do that you know you're
talking specifically i think about
about the research community i i and my
colleagues at seafarer have been
thinking about
the public and engaging the public
around ai do you think we have to
to do both um
well obviously i'm kind of focused more
on the education of students like the
graduate students as well as the
undergraduates
just just kind of running into the maybe
like
advice for students i think uh go ahead
i would say like we need to learn the
fundamentals properly there are
no shortcuts right so a lot of times
when we think of ai we think of
perhaps downloading some toolbox that is
that makes doing research convenient but
those those should be more like a
jump start right uh there's still no
shortcut in learning the math
learning the fundamentals um and canada
being one of the
places where we really value fundamental
research this is especially important
um and i would say this extends not uh
beyond students uh this is also for
everyone involved i i've talked to many
of my friends who are actually
well educated and they are aware of ai
but i would say that
in general i really hope to see people
understand the fundamentals fundamentals
a little bit more
great yeah maybe more events like this
in fact
that that could help yeah that's that's
that's part of why we do it for sure
absolutely
okay i'm going to take a few questions
uh from the audience now we've had lots
of great questions come in
and i want to share one with you that's
uh particularly been upvoted
by a number of individuals and and uh
people uh
putting their thumbs up for this one
it's uh it's coming in from joshua so
it's
you know it's a loaded question uh what
should happen to make sure
ai for social good applications are
developed even when the profit motive
is not sufficient to motivate companies
so you know how do we make sure
that you know ai for goods applications
are
really a priority for us as a research
community a research and innovation
community
when the private sector and their profit
motive is not
uh is not high enough for them to be
involved thoughts on
on that balance anybody want to join up
i'd like to start by saying it helps to
have a monetary incentive
obviously but when that isn't there
i think in the research community can
fairly easily be convinced that this is
an important problem to look at
i think the community that needs to be
convinced is the industry the business
and the general public um sometimes
they're just not aware
um and and possibly even i mean i i
believe in a multi-pronged approach so
possibly even
sort of the regulatory or policy bodies
um
one um you know analogy i like to use
is you know industries like telecom
where i
worked for many years ago have standards
um
that their protocols must abide by and
that's important for the communication
but for areas where you don't need that
you still have certain
guidelines like many years ago the
consumer protection
agencies were very important and their
work led to things like having labels on
clothing irons that say don't iron while
you're wearing your clothes
so um and you know no one's saying that
clothing irons shouldn't be produced and
shouldn't exist
but the harm that can be produced from
it was recognized
so in the same way i think for ai
products and services
i think we all agree that they're very
important and impactful
but the harm that they may result in
is not properly recognized and so maybe
you know we need something like
something like these consumer protection
agencies
um that allow people to be educated
about the harms
and how they can be safeguarded so if
the people are then
aware of this then they can push on
using their
you know where they spend their money on
they can push the industry or businesses
in certain directions
yeah absolutely i'm reminded uh again to
go back to healthcare where it's you
know a highly regulated
sector in canada and the us and both the
fda and health canada
you know actively and carefully examine
machine learning applications uh very
closely before they're implemented
within
you know within health systems and and
they are it's happening
um and so that's that's a step in the
right direction anything else on um
on public kind of private sector go
ahead dave i can i can i can step in a
bit
so i think that one component is
using our voices not necessarily in a
research capacity
but in the capacity of thought leaders
to add to the conversation about
what best policies and best practices
are um we have
we have leadership roles that don't
involve
necessarily coming up with a new
algorithm people
it is important for the community to use
its voice in that way
and then i think another component of
this
and and then that does involve informing
stakeholders of what the capabilities of
systems are and what they can do to best
incentivize
incentivize meaningful impact
and that also means informing ourselves
what what that means
but i think another component is
remembering
that research needs to be scoped with
impact in mind from the get-go it's not
a question of i wrote a great paper with
a great project and now i'm going to
look for a way to make it impactful oh
wait
i don't see a path to impact this is why
one should work with stakeholders from
from like the initial scoping of a
project and the development of the
project in addition to the deployment of
the project because once you get to
deployment
if you haven't scoped it together with
the people who will ultimately be using
it it's too late
there are ton of opportunities where the
incentives are aligned right now and
making sure that one is working with the
people who will be deploying
your projects can help you ensure that
you are working in a space
where you will be able to have the
impact that you want
that's great david thank you for that
and it is actually your
response speaks to one of the other
questions that came in
uh that that reads what do you see as
the role of individual researchers
versus the organization or external
players like governments
ensuring that ai is used in socially
beneficial ways so i want to
sort of um share that one with the other
members of the panel
what do you see as your role uh as
individual researchers
in you know being a voice around uh
responsible use of ai anybody
yeah i can i can chime in on this i
think
as uh individual researchers um
a we serve two roles one is education
which is
educating students undergraduate at the
graduate level
and teaching them to
create new algorithms and machine
learning in robotics and health care and
climate science
and it's i think that educational
component
of it is a big part of the role that we
can play
in order to make sure that the effort
that we put
in is multiplied by the students uh
who learn from us and and as long as we
incorporate in them a sense of you know
responsibility
uh a sense of values in uh in how to
ensure that these applications are used
responsibly
i think that's one of the most impactful
ways that uh
we can help because ultimately that's
who we spend a lot of time with
the students um the second way is
i i think i agree with david is um uh
having our voices heard in a variety of
different scenarios and ensuring that
the
ideas we put forth are ones that
are consistent with these notions of
safety and responsibility
and responsibly using the more technical
approaches that we develop
great thank you okay we're i've got two
minutes left on the clock or maybe even
less
um so we're gonna switch to sort of
final thoughts and i'd love to just have
each of you
give us in sort of 30 seconds let's call
it 20 seconds or less
tell us you know your best advice for
graduate students interested in your
particular area of machine learning
what should they be doing now to prepare
for their future careers
in academia and industry mo we'll start
with you
yeah as i mentioned earlier we need to
learn the fundamentals properly right no
shortcuts
um we need to in robotics we need theory
how the theory translates to code and
how code translates to robots
moving in the physical world right um
and don't be afraid to collaborate with
other faculty members other than your
supervisor
and internships are great so just get
all the expertise all the
all the expertise wherever you can get
that's great thank you niddy
your best advice for graduate students
so i think
my topic is necessarily
multidisciplinary and necessarily
has a clear and immediate impact on
society
so i would suggest that they
make themselves aware of actual real
impacts like real examples that
you know journalists have investigated
on where privacy breach has occurred or
where
fairness or bias questions arise um i
think that's important
and also second what most said which is
understanding the fundamentals because
things like
privacy and fairness you know there
sometimes they're even hard to
intuitively say what they mean to us
and they may be even harder in a
mathematical way to define what they are
and that's really important you know we
need to be rigorous about these
definitions
and about how we derive these in order
to then
create algorithms that um that mitigate
these problems
and so the fundamentals are important
and multi-disciplinary you know don't be
afraid to talk to
uh people in in law or in philosophy
to get a more well-rounded understanding
absolutely
rahul over to you best place for grad
students yeah
i i think there's uh two pieces of
advice that i would really have
um i would echo most thoughts on a focus
on
foundational knowledge so when you think
about
classes don't don't think of them as
i want to learn the most advanced topic
first i think it's much
it's very much in your interest to take
the more foundational
topics on the algebra optimization
stochastic processes
and really this is because machine
learning is fundamentally
just a melting pot of different sub
disciplines
and it and it has always been that way
uh and so
uh being very good and uh having strong
foundations is crucial to any future
success
in this sub area and the second thing
that i'd say is uh in
at least what i found when i was
studying is the fact that i think
uh patterns are sort of universal and i
think if you
learn to recognize patterns that exist
in
different classes that you're taking and
have a conceptual framework by which you
can learn to manipulate them
that's an incredible skill to have
because
at the end of the day a lot of ideas are
rediscovered and reused in different
subfields and being able to flexibly
move within fields
and describe how one idea relates to
another
in a completely separate arena it will
only strengthen
uh sort of the mental models you have of
the world and ultimately
lead to more interesting kinds of
research ideas great great advice david
last word to you
yeah so to echo what other people have
said
learn the fundamentals but not just
machine learning
learn the fundamentals of whatever areas
you're looking to integrate with machine
learning
and go in with humility recognize that
each of these other areas of application
has
decades or centuries of great work in it
and machine learning is not suddenly
going to solve all those problems
um or if it does solve some of those
problems
it's going to do that only by
integrating with all of that existing
knowledge
and by really carefully working with
people who are expert in in
those areas and if you want to have an
impact start from the problem
whether it's a theoretical or an applied
problem start from the problem
and let the tools that you use
evolve to match the problem don't go in
assuming that the
fanciest newest tools are best and then
paradoxically often that is actually
what will lead to foundational
innovation
that is what will lead to the
breakthroughs in from an algorithmic
perspective to
is really being driven by what people
need
this is this is great advice and it's
been such a fabulous conversation i
i hate to have to cut it off but i'm
afraid that is all the time we have for
today
so thanks so much to all of you all of
our panelists for sharing their insights
and experience
experiences we're really thrilled to
have you as part of the canada cfr ai
chairs program
and thanks to the audience for for great
questions and discussion over the chat
this has been
fantastic
you